blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman there is a lot that we still
don't know
about the shooter in georgia who
tragically
killed eight people at a massage parlor
on tuesday but it
increasingly seems that the early claims
that race was not a motivating factor
for the shooter those claims appear to
be falling apart
including based on some new witness
testimony given to
a south korean newspaper that has been
covering the story so
to catch everybody up the suspect is a
21 year old male
he is alive he was taken into custody on
tuesday
after this horrific shooting at a
massage parlor in georgia that left
at last count eight dead and one injured
and police have had a chance to
interview him this doesn't always happen
in these situations where the shooter
either at their own hand or that of the
police
uh often will end up dead not the case
here
police speak to the shooter and the
initial
belief by many was this was clearly an
anti-asian hate crime this was an
individual targeting asian individuals
but then it wasn't so clear and um it
it it could be partially that and
partially what they are describing as
sex addiction which i i'm hearing incel
as someone who's involuntarily celibate
um
but the point is i have no interest in
prematurely saying it's one thing or the
other
or neither or both what i know is that
the law enforcement law enforcement in
the u.s
and the american right will often
characterize
shootings by white men differently than
they characterize shootings by non-white
men
that we know and because of that we're
sort of on
alert as we hear and try to determine
what the motive was here and there's no
question that
people often will play koi with terms
like terrorist
lone wolf and these other types of terms
in this case it's just early it's a
tragedy either way
but we know most of the victims are
asian now yesterday there was a
very strange press conference with some
of the police
and i'm going to play a clip for you of
captain jay baker of the cherokee county
sheriff's office saying that
the shooter had a bad day and he was at
the end of his rope
on the day that he killed eight people
and many people rightly reacting by
saying
this guy chair the the guy from the
cherokee police jay baker
he almost sounds like more sympathetic
to the shooter than to the victims in
some strange way take a look at this
video
the investigators they interviewed him
this morning and i they got that
impression that yes he
he understood um the gravity of it and
he was
pretty much fed up and then at the end
of his rope and uh
and yesterday was a really bad day for
him and this is what he did anymore
uh i'm not gonna go to i don't know if
he was remorseful or not
he was fed up and had a really bad day
and killed eight people just kind of
strange language for describing what
happened it almost sounds again more
sympathetic to the shooter than the
victims
i think that's the bizarre thing but
okay maybe race wasn't a factor we don't
know yet
and then maybe not shockingly after this
bizarre
press conference we learn that jay baker
the georgia sheriff's spokesman you
heard from there has previously posted
xenophobic covet shirts on facebook
where he said he loves his shirt and the
shirt
is a shirt that says covid19
imported virus from china c-h-y
hyphen n a so now maybe we're doubting
what this guy
says and then we get reporting from the
south korean newspaper chosun
which interviewed victims and reports
that the atlanta shooter
said to a witness or a witness heard the
shooter say
i'm going to kill all asians and we've
translated the article from korean the
reporter is huang ji yoon
uh it includes reports of interviews
with witnesses
and the quote that on the 17th the hong
kook ilbo atlanta
quoted an employee a a member of the
gold massage
spa where the shooting took place and
said that the suspect
at the time of the crime said that he
would quote
kill all asians it is known that this
witness
mr a was in the store at the time of the
shooter
shooting but managed to evacuate and
then gave this information to nearby
korean businesses so it's becoming
harder
and harder to believe that a guy saying
he's going to kill
all asians wasn't at least partially
motivated by race
here is another clip in this one frank
reynolds a cherokee uh
county sheriff says that this appears to
be sexual addiction not racism take a
look
uh he we did interview him last night he
is currently in our facility at the
cherokee county adult detention center
we were able to interview him with the
atlanta police department and fbi
he made indication indicators that
he has some some issues potentially
sexual addiction and may have frequented
some of these places
in the past and but as the chief
indicated is still early on we still
have a lot of
things to process and so
he should be at an arraignment tomorrow
at some time early
morning to late morning and we will keep
you up
to date we have a press release that
captain baker has put together
available to our media folks if you
don't have that
i think we have some printed copies that
he'll be uh happy to give to you
uh i'm happy to answer any questions
that you may have every moment
so are you saying when you talk to the
suspect he says he has a sexual
addiction
conviction but i'm sure you asked him
was this racially motivated was this
racially motivated
um as the chief indicated uh it's still
early
but uh the indicators right now are uh
uh it may not be uh it may be targets of
opportunity
uh again we're we believe that he
frequent these places in the past
and may have been lashing out
and part of that is is in your media
packet as well
the working theory is a sexual addiction
issue rather than a
racial profile during our interviews
uh we asked that specific question and
uh and
that did not appear to be uh the motive
for for for
until the end
according to authorities the suspect
intended to also target the pornography
industry in florida
before he was apprehended and again the
statements uh we
there's a claim that the shooter said
i wasn't motivated by race or politics i
was motivated by my addiction to sex
the claims from the witness about i'm
here to kill all asians
certainly seem to contradict that now i
don't know that it necessarily has to be
one or the other
uh you could have someone who you know i
guess the term incel
is sort of pejorative but it's an
individual frustrated by his
um by his celibacy their celibate but
they don't want to be celibated for a
variety of different reasons
they're unable to find relationships
with if you're interested in the
opposite sex as it appears this person
was
members of the opposite sex it could be
both it could be racially motivated
and in cell motivated or more one or
more the other
so whether or not this was racially
motivated
uh there have been many racially
motivated shootings
whether this one is racially motivated
doesn't change that racially motivated
shootings are a problem in the united
states
some people immediately said of course
this is racially motivated and anyone
saying otherwise
is lying to you or dishonest others have
been saying there's no way this is
racially motivated and we shouldn't look
for that
even some on the left in fact have been
saying stuff like that from what we know
so far
there is certainly reason to suspect
that race was
one of possibly more than one motivation
let's continue to allow the information
to lead us to the answer
i have no political
or emotional attachment to it being one
or the other
but what we do know is there at least
now is a report
of the shooter saying i'm here to kill
all asians
we will see what comes out we'll see
what else we learn about this sheriff
spokesperson who posted
xenophobic china shirts to facebook
uh every every detail continues to just
be
more and more alarming we've mentioned
previously that joe biden came into
office or his first
approval rating once in office was the
highest
initial approval rating of any president
in nearly 30 years in fact
28 to be exact dating back to bill
clinton's first
year in the white house in 1993.
it is now not just one poll yesterday's
politico morning consult poll
continues to have joe biden polling very
strongly let's take a look at the full
scope of the numbers right now joe biden
with
62 percent approval 62
approval remember donald trump did not
get to 50
approval even once during his entire
presidency
the coveted relief bill once passed
still
roughly the same level of support 72
percent of americans
supporting the coveted relief bill 56
percent of americans
believe joe biden is doing a good job on
the economy typical that democratic
presidents don't poll that well on the
economy
that's a long-standing uh statistical
reality
66 approval for joe biden on coronavirus
remaining in that mid to high
60s level so these are very
strong numbers and seeing joe biden's
approval on coronavirus stimulus
reminded me once again not a single
republican voted for that bill
many republican voters supporting covet
relief
zero republican votes in the house of
representatives zero republican votes
in the senate for this coveted relief
bill and so that gets us to the question
of whether republicans
need to recalibrate their thinking on
voting against something that you have
essentially a super majority of the
country wanting supporting and needing
the answer may not be yes and what i
mean by that is
if republican no votes in the house and
senate on covet relief
which is popular have no consequences in
2022
why would they vote for it if there is a
political case to be made for i voted
against the pork
and i voted against the you know
overspending and what about the debt and
what about the deaths you know whatever
if it's not going to affect them in 2022
with their own base
and i remain skeptical that it will
maybe republicans don't need to
recalibrate their votes
to be reflective of what their
constituents want i don't know
given the circumstances the situation
joe biden was handed the hyper
polarization of the country
and and uh party the republican party
that has been feeding
a lie uh to their voters for two months
that joe biden actually won
given all of that these are really good
numbers they may not remain
i said before if biden doesn't get
coveted stimulus done
soon like within i said you know about a
week ago i said within 10 days or
14 days ago i said within 10 days and it
passed last week
if biden doesn't get it done it would be
a major failure and it will probably
tank his approval
he got it done people are getting cash
and they don't care
you know if you just got 1400 or 2800 or
whatever
do you care if it happened via budget
reconciliation or you got the money
because of 60 votes
no people don't care about that outside
of
you know the political beltway and
people who follow politics really
closely
and this probably buys biden
six weeks eight weeks and then the
question becomes
what next does the vaccine roll out
continue to improve
because cases are starting to level out
even though we're vaccinating we have to
vaccinate more quickly
we'll have to see what the next thing is
for joe biden and by the way
these numbers 62 percent approval etc
biden has these numbers without even
doing a press conference fox news and
newsmax and others
would have you believe that joe biden
not having done a press conference yet
is essentially the biggest scandal since
watergate at this point in time
it's not something that most american
people care about most american
people don't even watch presidential
press briefings
however joe biden will be doing one a
week from today thursday the 25th
and of course i will be covering it the
day after joe biden's press conference
the 26th
we're doing a one-day membership special
we are
blowing out huge discounts these
discounts are not illegal
but they're definitely immoral in some
sense i'm kidding
march 26th big discount if you want to
be notified about it to get a membership
just get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com and then
friday morning next friday morning you
will be given specific instructions
how to sign up for this disgustingly
discounted membership
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist
and what they do is take thousands of
popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in
15 minutes blinkist makes sure that
you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
the david pakman show unbeknownst to
many
is actually funded by viewers and
listeners who get memberships
on my website joinpakman.com
not everything is a sales pitch though
something you can do
absolutely for free is join the
discussion
at the david pakman show subreddit
davidpakman.com
slash reddit something like uh
i don't know it's it's got to be close
to 30 000 of our viewers and listeners
now subscribe to
the subreddit a few interesting posts i
spotted this morning that i want to
point out to you
our friend the eggman showed up he is on
the subreddit
and he says my dream ticket and
nightmare ticket in
2024 al franken anthony weiner
is the progressive d dream team sexual
allegations aside
mike pence mike pillow 2024
is the nightmare that ruins sleep the
eggman of course signing off with his uh
typical
shalom uh yeah i am i'm not so
sure about frank and weiner
frankenweiner may be a tough sell
i think strategically doesn't mean al
franken's not a brilliant guy
doesn't mean anthony weiner uh is not a
excellent
debater and all that i think that's a
tough one um
and as far as the right goes my money
would be if you give me an
even money bet is the 2024 ticket mike
pence and mike pillow
mike lindell of course i say it is not
i'm taking the no bet on that one but
interesting to hear from the eggman
there
user bread tube forever posted what's
tulsi gabbard
up to you might be asking it turns out
tulsi was on fox news comparing cancel
culture
to isis and al qaeda in a fox news
interview
yes i don't think tulsi is doing
anything
that's surprising to anyone that
has been uh paying attention to tulsi
gabbard
for some time and then user smm
97 has a tip for listening to the david
pakman show
pro life tip listen to the david pakman
show on 1.3 x
speed concentrated pacman
saying increasing the playback speed
brings a bit more energy to the
broadcast more info in less time
sometimes i even go for 1.5 to 1.66
speed give it a shot and try it out for
yourself and some people reporting
in the comments that they actually
listen to the show on 2xspeed
you know i've talked with other
podcasters about whether
we find it offensive that people speed
us up to listen to the episodes more
quickly i really don't i mean
there for some people listening to shows
is something you do
sort of like for pleasure some people
can you imagine some people find it
relaxing i know some people fall asleep
to the sound of my voice because it's so
uh to some uh uh a soperific
but um i i don't if you're just trying
to get
information you have a bunch of podcasts
you're listening to i take no offense to
people listening more quickly
i sometimes do that with certain types
of content but if you're just
listening for pleasure rather than to
cram like for an exam
then maybe you listen at 1x and i know
sometimes i
i don't speak that quickly um
and so i take no offense whatsoever
listen at any speed that you want
just be aware that the show will start
sounding like ben shapiro's show
at about 2x and that may be triggering
to some people
join the discussion join the subreddit
it's free at davidpakman.com
reddit yesterday during the press
briefing of
a white house press secretary jen saki
there was a clarification about joe
biden's tax plan when joe biden said
nobody earning under 400
000 dollars a year we'll see an increase
in taxes did joe biden mean individuals
earning up to 400k or did joe biden mean
households earning up to 400k
during yesterday's press briefing jen
saki clarified
that it means households that is
different
than four hundred thousand dollars per
person it's four hundred thousand
dollars
per household and within moments on fox
news
right wing host charles payne as well as
republican senator chuck grassley
were saying look look we told you
joe biden is coming for middle
income people take a look at this clip
so then
what if we go the exact opposite way we
know taxes were
promised where and elections have
consequences but i don't think
anyone thought that the president
president biden was talking about
a household making 400 000 i always tell
people senator
be careful when you pick up your
torching and pitchforks sooner or later
you might end up in front of your own
house
the middle income people of this country
are smart enough to know that when they
hear a politician
or even the president united states say
that only high
income people the very wealthiest are
going to pay the tax
they know better if you go
there you're going to eventually end up
paying
taxi taxing middle-income people so
there are two relevant parts here
first is is four hundred thousand
dollars
as a household income is that middle
income
that's the first question the second
question is
are these the folks we should be
targeting for higher taxes so
when you say 400 000 for a household
that could be two people making 200k
each that could be someone makes 175 and
someone makes 25
could be uh you know 350 and 50. total
400
000 that puts you in the top two percent
of households in the united states so by
definition you're not in the middle
if you're in the top two percent now you
could say well
you're in the middle like you know you
anything that goes down to the second
percentile
and up to the 98th counts as middle and
then you've got
two percent of people that are poor and
two percent of people that are rich
i don't think most people would imagine
that the meat of the curve
is the middle 98 percent for example uh
or the middle
96 percent by definition if you're in
the top two percent you're not in the
middle income now you can go and look at
this for yourself if you go to dqydj.com
you can type in any household income if
you type in 400 000 for example
you will see you're in the 98th
percentile the top to get into the top
two percent this is 2019 data
to get into the top two percent you had
to make as a household
387 000 it's a little higher now
probably because of inflation
it's right around four hundred thousand
a year puts you in the top two percent
now the second part is actually more
interesting to me
you can like they're they're just wrong
that 400k
is middle income you're in the top two
percent the more interesting part is
you can absolutely make the case that we
should be targeting
not people who as individuals might only
make 200 000
as part of a 400 000 household you
should be looking at people that are
making 5 million a year
20 million a year 200 million a year the
billionaires that there's so much more
meat on the bone there that you
shouldn't even include
400 000 households right now now that is
a valid argument in the sense that
you're not denying reality you're not
saying 400k is middle income now 400k is
still in the top
two percent but you should be targeting
the top one percent or the top
0.5 or the top 0.2
400 000 is a lot of money in any city
but four hundred thousand in manhattan
with three kids
is nowhere near the same as four hundred
thousand dollars as a couple with no
kids in alabama
so you just open this up to more debate
potentially if you make this
about 10 million a year and up or
20 million a year and up there's no
debate in any city
maybe if you have a thousand kids right
but but in any city with one two three
four kids
that's a ton of money anywhere maybe you
start there
um and that is a different discussion
and one that
certainly could be had but there is no
way to say
biden's coming for the middle class
by starting tax increases at 400 000
it's it's just look at a bell curve it's
not the case
um and and by the way there's one other
hypocrisy here
charles payne and chuck grassley talking
about
middle-income people making 400 000
but a 15 minimum wage is too much
that's just another level of how
everything is just political posturing
none of this is
none of this is honest or they're really
that dumb
you you decide which it is i think that
it's that they're not honest
we'll have more coverage of this on our
instagram at david pakman show and find
my latest pastry haul by following me
on instagram david.pakman
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpackman.com
that's
join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by
all means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
today i'm going to be speaking with dan
kavalak who is a labor and human rights
attorney and also
author of the book cancelled this book
the progressive case
against cancel culture uh it's great to
have you on dan
it's great to be here david thank you so
the reason i'm interested in this
is um there are certainly a range of
views
across the political spectrum about this
issue of so-called cancer culture and
what what counts as cancer culture and
what doesn't
but even within the left there is some
disagreement as to whether it's taking
place
what counts what should be done maybe
start
by kind of giving us your sense of
relative to the idea that we hear
on right-wing media about this as a sort
of
speech suppression politically based
epidemic that is taking place in media
and academia and across the social and
cultural
uh areas how does your position compare
to that
as a starting point yes compared to the
right wing position i think
mine is certainly uh different
uh first of all i'm not hysterical about
it i mean i
i try to deal with it in a reason way i
i certainly am concerned about it
um you know they i'll just give examples
like i'm not concerned
about the fact that pepe lepews not
going to be in the next uh
this uh movie yeah um that was decided
by the producers
and you know i certainly think
that he is a problematic character who
basically his only thing he ever did was
assault the
uh other uh skunk um the same thing with
the
um dr seuss uh issue i mean
the um estate itself apparently if dr
seuss decided to get rid of these six
books which no one ever heard of and
which you know were offensive and i
think dr
seuss um progressed in his thoughts
as he got older right um
and and that actually is a good segue
into what i am concerned about what
would concern me is if all of dr
seuss's books were cancelled because
of his earlier works okay the concern i
have about
cancer culture particularly on the left
is that it seems to me there's a lack of
forgiveness
and chance for redemption for people
you make one mistake and i've seen this
all of us have seen this many times and
that's why
people who deny the cancer culture exist
i i just think are not
being honest we see many times someone
will do something
that is offensive or barely offensive or
seen by someone as offensive and they're
immediately shut out people call for
them to be fired
uh sometimes they'll get fired um
that concerns me so let's break down
that process so that we can maybe even
figure
out which is the part that concerns you
because so let's imagine a situation
where
someone tweets something that we agree
is offensive
not related to their work while they are
on the weekend or you know there was
this story that john
ronson talks about in his book so you've
been publicly shamed a woman who tweeted
um something about white versus black
people getting aids as she stepped onto
a flight and then when she landed it
exploded into an international story
and photographers were waiting for her
and whatever okay so
the thing is said then there is a public
outcry from people who say this is bad
sometimes you'll see the public contact
the employer of the individual
and ask for them to be fired even if
what was said
doesn't does arguably not directly
relate to the person's job
the employer will then sometimes put out
a statement
sometimes they'll say we are
disciplining the person sometimes they
will
fire the person now at every individual
level
people tweeting outrage seems to be
something that
i don't have a problem with people
tweeting outrage people demanding that
the person be
fired is a question mark for me and this
this has been done to me
before in in fact as well in the sense
that
certainly calling a business if you find
out the person works somewhere and
you're going to say
if this person works for you i'm not
going to be a patron of your business
certainly something i can't say is wrong
to do although i might disagree with it
and then the firing decision an employer
can decide as long as they're not
discriminating on the basis of protected
class
it's no longer good for our business to
have this person working for us so like
the pieces all when you break them down
the way i'm doing it
aren't particularly concerning so like
which aspect is it you are most worried
about
well first of all i mean the context
is everything and i mean it's one thing
if you just if you find out someone is
an avowed white supremacist
okay at night dresses up you know in a
hood and
in his part of the ku klux klan this is
a person
with bad motives bad intentions
i think how you deal with that person
would be different
than someone who who is otherwise well
intentioned who says something
inadvertently sure uh offensive or does
something inadvertently
uh offensive i think they need to be
treated differently i
i don't think you should pile on someone
even on social media who makes a mistake
and who says look i'm sorry
right and that happens a lot right and
usually even after the i'm sorry
it doesn't end right and i certainly
don't think you should try to get
someone like that fired except in the
most egregious circumstance
i don't see getting someone fired in
most circumstances
some act of social activism i see it
as uh something counter to solidarity
with your fellow workers with your
fellow comrades many times
um and this concerns me greatly
especially in the academy now and i talk
about this in my book i think a lot of
people don't understand
that the academy has gone through a huge
transformation
in recent decades from tenured
professors
on the most part to now adjunct
professors most
professors now are adjunct what does
that mean means they don't have tenure
they have no job security
they get paid poverty wages
uh i'm an adjunct for example i get
three thousand dollars per class i teach
at the law school i may teach
50 students to pay 40 grand a year
to attend it right and i get three grand
for the whole class and can be fired
mid semester i have not you know i'm
you know basically a glorified uh
you know gig worker right right yeah and
i've taught adjunct as well
at boston college and i've had a similar
experience and to call
lightly and i think many times it's
likely for someone like that to be fired
is kicking down it's not punching up
it's not
fighting you're not taking on the man in
fact i agree with you
is uniting with the man right the
administrators who make a lot of money
hundreds of thousands of dollars if not
over a million
against these lowly adjuncts and you see
this
a lot um yeah a woman named amy siskind
a democratic activist uh tried to get me
fired for from boston college because
i i responded to a tweet of hers saying
that the 2020
nominee uh or maybe it was even 2016
2020 shouldn't be white or a man and i
said that seems to me
to be wrong to to disqualify someone on
the basis of sex or race and she tried
to get me fired
from boston college and that's wrong but
what i'm hearing from you
is more that you just think sometimes
these tools are wielded when they
shouldn't be like there's more egregious
and less egregious cases and sometimes
you just think
the action doesn't rise to warranting a
call to be fired for example
i think it would be a rare case where
that would be legitimate
let me put it that way but i do think
you know there's something
that people now refer to the overton
window yeah
you've probably heard that that there is
a line
there are lines of demarcation again i
think if someone
is in a vowel racist and a vowed white
supremacist
um you know uh particularly in a
sensitive position
of power um i think it's legitimate
to call that person out publicly
and and with their employer but who gets
to who gets to decide what rises to what
level and if the position is sensitive
well that's a great question i mean i
think uh
obviously it's up to the individual
who's doing the attempted canceling if
we want to say that
okay has to use some judgment um
but i think giving what i'm illustrating
is
that you would do this very rarely you
know
there's you know not that many uh
there are obviously uh uh avowed white
supremacists but
you know most of the people we come in
contact with on a daily basis are not
that and most of the people that are
being canceled
are not that in fact you know the irony
is
uh to calling someone a racist or a
sexist
is only damaging to people who don't
want to be racist or sexist right i mean
if you're in a vowed racist that's a
compliment i got a guess
so what would be what would be an
example of someone who
said was called a racist and then fired
but what they said was just a
lapse in judgment and really they
shouldn't have been
okay well i'll give an example um
from my book and why i wrote the book
because of something that happened in
pittsburgh
and this was not someone who was fired
but in a way it was it was even
greater than being fired so um in
pittsburgh
we have this peace and justice group
called the thomas merton center
and it was founded 50 years ago
co-founded by someone named molly rush
a long time peace activist and also
someone who's advocated
for economic and racial justice
during the george floyd protest of last
summer
she uh posted on facebook reposted
like someone had posted it and she just
hit share which many of us do
you know without thinking she posted
this meme
with a picture of martin luther king and
it said
never rioted never looted change the
world
immediately people started jumping on
her
on facebook attacking her as a racist
attacking her family who defended her
calling them white trash she apologized
on facebook publicly
but that wasn't enough what what ended
up happening
happening is the thomas merton center
the board of the thomas merton center
put out a letter
both to all uh thomas merton center
members
and uh publicly on facebook
saying they could no longer work with
molly rush yeah
after 50 years and this is
uh you know so the argument was this
meme was racist because
you shouldn't tell african americans how
to fight for their liberation right if
if there's some violence that ensues
it's not for us to say and of course
though as i point out my book
if you look at a lot of the violence
that happened
a lot of it probably the vast majority
was not done by
african americans it was done either by
young white
anarchists usually young white males
or young white male right wingers trying
to
either inflame the situation or to
delegitimize
black lives matter so uh
calling those people out
uh why is that problematic in fact in
portland as i mentioned there were
newspaper articles that quoted people
from
black lives matter and from the naacp
saying that the violence that took place
night after night in portland
at around midnight and later
had nothing to do with black lives
matter yeah yeah something else
this was again young white people
who were anarchist or whatever they were
who decided they wanted to do what they
wanted to do which was
attack the federal courthouse night
after night i think this is a great
example i mean listen if this example is
as you describe it and i have no reason
to doubt it i'm just saying i'm
what i know about it is what you're
telling me exactly this would be one
where i i agree
this this sounds like the wrong solution
but in a
i guess where i worry is that in a
country of 331 million people
there's examples of everything every
good company that's a big company is
gonna have a hundred
or a thousand customer experiences that
sound terrible but they represent
very little in the scope of the how the
company deals with customers as an
example
you know uh i i worry that the
this is being called an epidemic when i
will
grant that in a country of 331 million
the example just you gave me sounds
terrible it sounds completely
counterproductive
to the goals of me as a person on the
left for example i'm with you if the
details are as described
i just don't see the epidemic and
individually it sounds like
you certainly defend the people the
right of people to express their
distaste on social media right like you
and i are on the same page there
yes absolutely and you certainly defend
the right
of individuals to tell a company i won't
do business with you
because of this whether they're right or
wrong you defend the right that they
have to do that
well certainly consumers have that right
they certainly have that legal right
they should
yeah again as a matter of discretion
sure
whether or a matter of conscience
whether they should do it
that that's another question but i see
people have the legal right to do that
and then businesses as as businesses
that exist
some are regulated in certain ways and
some some are others as long as they're
not breaking any laws
they can also decide having a certain
employee is bad for us and it could hurt
profits or whatever
we don't want this employee working for
us that you agree with
yes of course so it sounds like really
it's the sometimes overbearing
activation of these tactics that you're
concerned about
well yes and again i i never use the
word epidemic
in my book or when i talk about this
yeah and i wouldn't use that
uh but i do think it is uh i
i think it is a frequently used
tactic uh against people particularly in
the academy the academy
is really
[Music]
soaked in this stuff let's pause our
conversation there with daniel cavallic
author of cancel this book
the progressive case against cancel
culture the full interview will be on
the david pakman show
youtube channel at youtube.com slash
the david pakman show
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash
david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on tv
or even listen on the radio patreon.com
david pakman show fox news propagandist
tucker carlson is really playing up this
fox news crisis at the border story of
course the crisis at the border
started three days after joe biden took
office it's amazing
how quickly he was able to start a
crisis at the border and fox news has
really been playing this up and
uh this is just a perfect red meat issue
for tucker carlson
and last night tucker did a segment on
his show
arguing that the country suddenly is too
crowded
and that crowded countries are unhappy
countries let's take a listen
to tucker carlson has there ever been an
administration
this reckless and destructive what's
happening on the border side will change
this country forever a lot of things
won't this will and you should know that
unlike other disasters mass illegal
immigration is permanent
no one ever really gets sent home over
the past 30 years the population of the
united states has exploded by nearly a
hundred
million people mostly due to immigration
were you even aware that that happened
you're not supposed to say a word about
it as every year the united states gets
steadily more
jammed with people and at the same time
more chaotic and less cohesive
as the open spaces shrink as nature
itself recedes in the face of yet
another strip mall
or apartment complex or fast food outlet
to serve the new people
this is becoming a crowded country and
crowded countries are ugly unhappy
countries
why are we letting that happen so there
are about five layers of things to talk
about here and i i really hope that
these
segments are instructive for i think
these are great because
we start with just like a cartoonish or
wacky thing from right-wing media
which i think interests a lot of people
but then we actually
look at the data behind a lot of these
things and hopefully we come out with a
better understanding of how the world
works
first of all is just the political
posturing and the hypocrisy
why do this segment 55 what is it 56
days into joe biden's presidency
but you never did it during donald
trump's presidency given that if the
issue is the country being crowded
during the time that donald trump was in
office the u.s population
increased by six to seven million
people and tucker said nothing about the
country being too crowded
and yet during joe biden's 50-something
days in office
during which the u.s population probably
increased by about a hundred thousand
people
all of a sudden now the country is just
stuffed full of people it's too crowded
the answer is to why he didn't do it
then and he's doing it now
is because he only cares about this
issue when a democrat is president
that's very simple
number two tucker often focuses
on what he considers the tragedy of
cities
which i guess he believes are sort of
war zone
hellscapes but the truth is that the us
is large cities surrounded by
gigantic areas with very few or almost
no people
in many states and in fact if you
actually
rank countries by overall population
density the us
i i think this will shock many of you
the us is 145th
in the world in population density
we are right behind mozambique and
venezuela
and the faroe islands in population
density
but just ahead of kyrgyzstan
latvia and estonia in population density
yes our population density is lower
than that of the pharaoh islands so it's
also not crowded many cities are
but people are choosing to live there
and if it became
too uncomfortable to live in those
cities there's plenty of open space that
people can find and if tucker's looking
for open space
certainly there's plenty for him as well
now then he gets to happiness in terms
of happiness
happiness i have studied in fact my
my masters here we go my master's
uh not really dissertation but
one of my like final master's papers was
on
uh happiness correlations and
there is no evidence that population
density
correlates with happiness however
a lot of economic factors do and people
can be happy
in cities or in suburbs or in rural
areas but it really
depends on having a job economic
stability
social connections access to health care
which is part of being able to sort of
determine what you want to do in life
and then lastly
population growth in the united states
is really slow right now
the population grew at the slowest rate
in 120
years between 2019 and 2020
just 0.3 percent
so this is another fake scandal
where tucker and fox and newsmax and
others
they want you to think that the
immigration crisis
suddenly is so bad that the country is
now crowded
by no measure is the united states
crowded
but then here's the additional layer
of irony the real population concern
is not about oh it's too crowded there's
no room
the real population concern is not
immigrants are flooding the
no it's none of that the population
concern
is climate change and sustainability
the most science-based concern about
you know you could say world population
or u.s population
is energy consumption and resource
depletion
and that's the one that tucker doesn't
actually
care about he at least doesn't talk
about it and he ridicules climate
science and he ridicules those
who are concerned about resource use in
the united states
and what was notably absent from that
rant
a fact-free rant a propagandistic rant
was the real concern about listen at a
certain point
what are we doing to the natural
resources of our planet what are we
doing in terms of emissions what are we
doing in terms of all of these other
things
if the con if the world population
continues increasing at the current pace
now
this ignores all sorts of population
dynamics and and theories
you know you've got um uh uh thomas
thomas malthus and there's all this
different literature about this
that's out there certainly it's beyond
tucker's segment but the point is if you
want to have a real conversation
about the impacts of an indefinitely
increasing population
it's a climate change conversation it's
an environmentalism conversation it's a
sustainability conversation
you're not going to find that on
tucker's show anytime soon that i can
assure you
hey this is um this i think this is
exciting
the david pakman show is hiring we have
a small team
and we very rarely have open positions i
get emails all the time from people
wanting to
uh intern or work part-time or offering
their services in different ways and we
essentially are almost never hiring
we are uh is it lucky blast fortunate
that um many of our our employees stay a
really long time
and we have a position that is available
and i want to tell you about it in case
you want to apply or you know somebody
that might want to apply
i will tell you at the end of this
segment how to express interest
and if you do anything outside of what
i'm saying to express interest we're
unfortunately going to have to ignore it
because
we have to set some guidelines and
create some structure here
so this is a position that is remote you
can be anywhere for this position
but that being said we mostly are
working on east eastern u.s
uh time zone all right this is a
multi-disciplinary position that
includes
social media and writing it includes
video editing it includes publishing of
content
and yes it includes some sales
no getting no no cold calling people on
the phone
but yes interacting with uh possible
advertisers and brands via email so i
think the easiest way to explain this
position to be
would be to tell you kind of like what a
typical day would look like the typical
day would
start with um making a bunch of
social media content and scheduling
posts maybe for that day maybe for the
weekend
this includes to our instagram this
includes
uh twitter this includes facebook tick
tock etc and other platforms we're going
to
expand to so first piece of it would be
working with the team to figure out
what did well yesterday on youtube let's
amplify some of that stuff
what funny memes do we have on reddit
etc all right that's piece 1 of the day
second part of the day we are looking
very strongly
at launching a second youtube channel we
have so much live stream content right
now
that there's lots of things that happen
on live streams that would be very
clipable
as individual clips but our main youtube
channel is essentially full
with the clips from the podcast and
interviews and this type of thing
so the ideal person would be able to
understanding the culture of the show
and what's interesting and what's funny
go through the previous days live stream
and pick out
a handful of moments either live calls
or reviews of clips or whatever the case
may be
that would be good stand-alone clips for
this second youtube channel working
under the tutelage of producer pat
cutting these titling them understanding
metadata thumbnails click bait titles
obviously you know
we will teach you clickbait titles and
managing this potential
second youtube channel very good that's
part two so we've got social media
and this new second channel we are
thinking of part three
is working under the tutelage of
producer
and business development uh mastermind
noah to um
do some sales outreach and this inc some
people may know this some people may not
we do ad sales not just for the david
pakman show but also for other shows we
are almost in a sense an ad
agency and we want to expand that so
working under the tutelage of noah
you would learn how do we grow our list
of
shows on which we place sponsors
how do we make initial contact with
sponsors and hopefully you would get to
the point
of negotiating your own deals as well
that would be part three of the job
um and then uh part uh well i guess
those are the three main parts and and
then the other thing would be uh also
learning the technical production of the
show
how is the show carried out on a daily
basis
uh such that if we were to have
um an illness like for example when i
had my appendectomy
well pat pat filled in for me but but
you wouldn't be expected to fill in for
me
but what if pat was out what if we had
to you know whatever you would
essentially learn to be a
backup producer for the show as well so
this for the right person
would be full-time it also may start as
part-time
and that would be absolutely fine it
would eventually be a full-time job with
benefits
the key things are less about technical
know-how
we've learned that we can really teach
people all of the tech skills
what we can't teach is being a really
good writer and written communicator
we can't teach uh go get em
type attitude and and people being uh
go-getters
we can't necessarily teach you know
working well in a fast-paced environment
working on four or five different things
each day so those are really the big
things
we are setting a requirement that you
either have to have a college degree
already
or be in your last semester right now
and that is
for a number of different reasons and to
reduce certain certain complications
if you want to apply we have a formal
job description that i can send
you can inquire with a letter of
interest and resume
or without one just asking for the
position description
the only way to send inquiries about
this job is
info davidpakman.com and please make the
subject of your email
job opening okay in the email
please confirm that you either have a
college degree or in your last
semester tell me a little bit about
meeting those requirements
of being a good written communicator
working well in teams working well in a
fast-paced environment et cetera
and um we are going to we we anticipate
i mentioned this on the stream yesterday
we're already getting a lot of interest
so we anticipate a lot of interest and
uh it's very very exciting
the team is growing we are growing
content we are growing a lot of
different things all right
i've said way too much i've gone on for
a long time but hopefully that gives you
a sense of what's going on and
info davidpakman.com is the one and only
place to inquire
no voicemails no visits to producer
pat's apartment
none of that all right we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
david p
this uh voicemail is very interesting
in terms of what it um suggests could
become the dividing line
between the vaccinated and the
unvaccinated in the future take a listen
to this
hey there david this is lance calling
from san jose
listening to your show today when you're
talking about republican reluctance to
get the vaccine to
whatever deny them deny covet or to own
the libs
i have a crazy prediction for probably
later this year
yeah that coveted deaths will have to be
reported
based on red cove deaths and blue
coveted deaths
or trump supporter kova deaths and trump
denounce reporter
i mean really it's really gonna not get
the vaccine
oh boy uh i guess stay away from alabama
and places like that
yeah so i mean listen you're never
really going to be able to say
red or blue coveted deaths in the sense
that we won't know the political
orientation
of those who who continue dying even
after the vaccines are widely available
and you can't really go by state because
you know
a texas coveted death could be some
liberal in
austin or it could be you know what
you're not going to know that but the
point
is a good one even if we won't know for
sure
if the most anti-vaccine group in the
united states
the two most anti-vaccine groups are
republican men
uh and trump supporters you at a certain
point
will have a significantly higher degree
of protection from the virus
among non-trump supporters and
non-republicans
and it could well be the case that in a
year or whenever vaccines are widely
available
maybe we already have a booster that
accounts for the variance
the group that will be
disproportionately unvaccinated may well
be
republicans right wingers and trump
supporters
and you could see a situation in the u.s
where like 80
of the deaths 85 of the deaths are
right-wingers that certainly
could be the case if the anti-vaxx
movement is going to continue
on covid remember other anti-vac like
measles has left in right-wing
anti-vaxxerism
uncovered the anti-vaxxerism is far more
on the right than the left
left you could indeed start to see that
split and
i don't want anybody to die i don't want
anybody to get sick even if they're
ignorant anti-vaxx republicans
so i would take no pleasure in that uh
let's just hope people realize the
importance of getting vaccinated
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today
fox news is claiming that reports about
the georgia trump phone calls
were wrong and that now everybody is
having to
retract the stories on them that's not
what's going on i'll explain the story
to you on the bonus show
we will also talk about you know for all
the discussion of the regular minimum
wage
the tipped minimum wage has been just
over two dollars an hour
for decades and it is not getting a lot
of discussion in the minimum wage
discussions
and then lastly the fcc is cracking down
on robocalls with uh record fines
will this make a difference i have some
robo-call stories to tell as well
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show get instant access to the
bonus show
by becoming a member at joinpackman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman